knees but first up she is the author of
this fight is our fight the battle to
save America's middle class senator
Elizabeth Warren
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you love California
the last liberal Bastion nah come on
come on people all across this country
are energized right now I want it I want
to maybe all energized across Laconia
but all across the country they don't
have a Democratic governor Democratic
senator Democratic Parliament we are
where liberalism is at the forefront
you've got to admit that look I actually
see this a little differently the way I
see it right now is that look at what
happened on health care I want to say
thank you to everything this audience
everybody out there who called or wrote
a letter or emailed or Facebook
Rodriguez back the biggest assault on
health care in the history of America
and it didn't happen because we had
enough Democratic votes in the house or
in the Senate what we had our voices and
we got out there and made them heard in
Washington
okay so let's talking about your book
first of all we don't forget you know no
we don't want to forget that important
thing and it's an important basis you
have which is about the middle class and
what's happened to them and let's be
honest it started with Reagan peace and
blessings be upon him
but it's again I mean you talk about the
period from 1980 to 2050 where the
middle class was before and where the
middle class was after 1980 tell us so
let's do the first part and then it's
1935 coming out of the Great Depression
all the way to 2016 year after year
after year basically GDP goes up America
gets richer it's a good story but
divided into time period one time period
to 1935 to 1980 what happens during that
time we have regulation of the big banks
giant companies we enforce antitrust
rules put a cop on the beat on Wall
Street have glass-steagall in place and
progressive taxation and make a lot of
investments boo that's right in an
opportunity in education in
infrastructure in research scientific
research medical research and so GDP is
going up 1935 to 1980 the 90% of America
everybody outside the top 10% the 90%
get 70 percent of all the income growth
in America and that happened across the
board
it happened Americans participated the
pie got bigger we all got a little more
to eat 1980 what happens then Ronald
Reagan deregulation fire the cops on
Wall Street and the big one cut taxes
for those at the top and then invest
less in education in infrastructure in
basic research 1980 to 2016 GDP keeps
going right on up this is the long arc
story in the book
GDP keeps going right on up and how did
the 90 percent to vacant 0% of the new
income growth nearly 100 percent of new
income growth in this country goes to
the top 10% that's why I wrote this book
is because we got to get in there and
fight back and that's what this book is
about about however
[Music]
[Applause]
well
let me fight back a little all right I'm
ready
because 1982 2015 there's some Democrats
in there although these terms of Barack
Obama
- terms of Bill Clinton so and sometimes
when they controlled the House and the
Senate - so what happened there
don't endemic rats bear some
responsibility for that though aren't
they supposed to put the brakes on this
originally no look it worked both ways
1935 to 1980 we also had some
Republicans who were president like
Tyson Hanna right a Nixon who actually
is the guy who started the Environmental
Protection Agency and a Consumer Product
Safety Commission great guy solid solid
you know I never thought the president
is nothing Nixon was really what next to
this guy I look at old clips of Bush and
I'm like wow oh those were the days
right yeah but like that but there
really is a point these are long arc
movement and basically what we've done
in America is we've tried two different
theories this is kind of the the thesis
of the book we tried the one where you
use progressive taxation you use some
sensible regulations to make sure the
playing field is level you know what we
built the greatest middle class on the
face but I think I can see why the real
Americans out there the Trump voters say
a pox on both their houses because this
trend you're describing was not
interrupted by Democratic
administrations well it was slowed down
some by Democratic administrations and I
want to be fair here Democratic
administrations are the ones yes well
put some of the brakes on who did
somewhat more antitrust enforcement and
let's keep in mind it's a Democratic
administration group that went for
universal health care with Obama care or
at least pushed in that direction and
dodd-frank and built my personal
favorite the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau yes so sitting out
okay so now we have another Republican
president who just presented another tax
plan which is I mean I've seen
Republican tax plans like this but not
quite as brazen because this one doesn't
even pretend it's just about wouldn't it
be great if rich people didn't
right but he's going to go to a rally in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania tomorrow and
tell his fans all about this about how
his kids are not going to have to pay
taxes because they get rid of the estate
tax and they're still with him they're
not with you explain to me what that
disconnection is actually I'm going to
push back I disagree with you when you
told his fans are not with you
hold on come on when when we like you
Pocahontas
it's when you talk about what's really
the basic pieces of a progressive agenda
raise the minimum wage expand Social
Security reduce the cost of college so
people don't get crushed by student loan
debt more not less regulated for animal
interactions not one thing a progressive
taxation make those at the top pay their
fair share America Democrats Republicans
independents libertarians vegetarians
America by about two to one are with us
on that the primary signature and that
is emeritus is what this is a disconnect
I'm talking about I agree with you their
wish to with you on the issues and then
they vote for him well then what what is
that problem and now I you know I'm not
a politician I don't up to be nice I say
people are stupid all the time so let's
not say that today because you are a
politician but don't they bear some
burden for not the people for not
looking into this a little more closely
and seeing who is really on their side I
mean Donald Trump ran as a populist and
now he presents his tax plan to Goldman
Sachs guys yeah get up there
thank God we didn't elect Hillary with
her Wall Street connect exactly and
present this plan on one page that
basically is you know let's give all the
money to the rich people because they
always do what's right with it you know
they thank God for the rich people
because they take that money they put it
back it trickles down on you you lucky
bastard
we've seen this before the voters have
seen it before his voters are not young
they lived through it how come they fall
for the con so look I think Donald Trump
tapped into a real anger in America
people are angry and let's face it they
are right to be angry they are angry
over the fact that young people can't
get an education without getting crushed
by student loan debt they are angry but
it's misplaced if they vote for him and
not EU so this is what how do we solve
that problem so we all agree the anger
is justified okay what's there but but
let's do it the first step is our sign
has to acknowledge the anger and have to
say yeah people are angry and they are
right to baby that's what I'm coding all
right people right everybody stop and
say there is anger and there is good
reasons for a lot of those real
Americans think that only Trump cares
about them and that Democrats only are
into identity politics and sometimes it
looks that way
what and since the Democrats lost every
election and they don't control one
branch of government shouldn't it
doesn't it behoove them to look at that
this is this is the reason I wrote this
book okay I wrote this book this is my
this is my life's work you know this is
you notice this is what I've worked on
forever and it's what happens to working
families you have the street cred for
this yes you know my background on you
yes and you know where I come from and
you know or do it it is the fact Here I
am I am I am the daughter of a janitor
who ended up as a professor at Harvard
Law School and as a United States
Senator because of America invested
[Applause]
I recognize that those opportunities
today are lost they are gone and so the
question for me is how are we going to
rebuild that America how are we going to
get enough people together to say that
democracy is going to work again that
this is not going to be a country run by
and for rich people only it's going to
be a I I do myself in this book to talk
about how we make our voices heard how
we come together and how we fight back
in fact I'll tell you something this
book is on a very hopeful note it ends I
went to Trump's inauguration I watched I
wanted to see it I wanted it burned in
my eyes you know my my view on this way
the fear was ever going to be a moment I
was like I'm too tired to get up all you
do is close my eyes like oh god I'm not
I'm ready I'm back in the fight but the
next day it's the next day when the
world change when the history of this
time is written sure it's going to be
about Donald Trump's election but you
know what it's going to be about it's
going to be about the day of the women's
March it's going to be about the day and
we have real evidence that it matters in
the fights over health care remember how
the Republicans in the health sixty plus
times had voted to repeal Obamacare you
remember how Donald Trent said on day
one right how many times did he say on
day one we're going to repeal Obama okay
so we lied once yeah exactly
exactly what but here's the deal we
really didn't have the votes in the
house of the Senate to stop him right
what stopped him was enough people
across this country and not just
Democrats who got engaged in the fight
who started talking about are you
kidding me you mean you want to change
the law so you could discriminate
against people with pre-existing medical
conditions and when they actually saw
the plan not twenty-four people million
people of health care coverage raised
costs for middle-class families so you
can give a tax break to those at the top
a handful of millionaires and
billionaires no way and so I get it that
that the first version of Trump care
failed because for some Republicans it
was not brutal enough but here's the
deal the rest of the Republicans were
not willing to follow them over that
cliff and the reason is because people
around this country made their voices
heard
we got a cap into that we got a magnet
and they need a leader you know I have
to say you know when you talk people get
very excited when Hillary stopped
talking they got excited so Donald Trump
[Music]
Donald Trump today was talking about
running against you next time no
pressure
senator Elizabeth
[Applause]
[Music]
how you go over this one